okay
camera
oh yay okay
guys sorry
oh my god this is a struggle bus
is this is why we call it a test
this is why this is a test not an actual
okay what up guys
um
okay
this is a very awkward ending not going
to lie in a picture so all right can you
guys hear us see us now
i just spilled water like twice
yeah it is not
it's like cords everywhere i don't know
how fresh and fit have so many girls on
because
this would be like
okay guys
before i start if you have watched two
or more of my lives
okay two or more of my lives and you do
not subscribe to the channel we have
beef also
purchase my we have beef sweatshirts
okay they're in they're like right under
this video if you look it'll be like
right under okay
so we were talking about what you look
for in a short-term partner and what you
look for in a long term
i feel like also though like i think
it's weird to say at my age because i'm
only 22. like
i'm i don't look for short-term partners
anymore i feel like oh really yeah i
feel like i'm just past that point in my
life yeah i need that
yeah i think
um well they say okay they say a girl's
they called her epiphany face
really and i
that's like basically when girls are
done like sleeping around a lot of times
they find god at this age okay they're
done sleeping around they want a
long-term partner they want to settle
down what age would you guess that would
be they think they say that's that
no guess again ellie's licking my ankle
uh 25
older 30 28 27 to 35 it's like typically
but they say if people have had rough
like childhoods it tends to be like
sooner
okay
i feel like
my i have a fear though
that like i'm only like i'm only 22.
yeah yeah like i've reached this phase
so early where i'm so over like the
meaningless like relationships
that like don't have any potential that
like i'm gonna be like 40 years old and
i'm gonna be like oh my god like i
regret like
oh my gosh that's another that's another
that's what they talk about a lot of
aunties and like just
well let me not like call anyone out
yeah yeah i know a lot of people that
are at that phase in their life they
settled down too young
and they are
like oh i wish i would have married like
for money like for example one of my
aunts she told me that she was like
um
like if i could have gone back because
she's married to like a teacher okay for
example and she's like if i could have
gone back and done it i would have
married for money
wow look at that like i was like shook
oh shook oh my god well that's okay you
know what um
i think like love they always say like
love is like a young person's game
because the older you get the more
practical you get
but that's nuts that she said she
wouldn't did she have the option to
marry for money before
um i don't think well granted they live
in a in a nice area of california
like the bay area and the area is very
expensive especially the area they live
in is like steph curry lives in there
okay yeah a very nice area and they live
in an apartment
so it's like
you know i think that when you're around
that all the time
um
that that makes it more of like uh
something you want when you're in that
environment well that's what they talk
about like a woman will like they call
it hypergamy right because she doesn't
know like any of these terms
no so hypergamy means like a woman like
basically is looking for her best option
like and so if she's in a room
full of like her hometown like she'll
look for the best option in her hometown
but if she's in like a nicer and nicer
room then that woman's like standards go
higher and higher
do you think that's true do you think
that's true
i don't know because it's kind of what
you described like because your your
aunt wishes she did better basically
because of where she lives like like
money wise at least no that makes sense
but i feel like also like you're a
product of your environment you know yes
yes it's like you can't if you're
surrounded by these people that take
like
these insane vacations to like aspen and
like hawaii on a whim and spend like
thousands and thousands of dollars
staying in like penthouse suites like
it's like i feel like it's almost
keeping up with like the joneses yes
like yeah keeping up with appearances
like you're trying to keep up with this
lifestyle that like you can't afford
like rationally and it's like you in
your social circle because like i feel
like social circles have so much to do
with that yes yeah that's so true but
that's kind of what we're talking about
like the woman's social circle yeah then
she wants her girlfriends and what not
in their husbands like it's almost like
they
would give anything just like they will
literally put themselves in hundreds of
thousands of dollars in debt just to
keep up with like this lifestyle that's
what i talk about a lot is like the
richest people i know don't look rich
you would never know i know someone
worth probably like between 50 and 100
million and the wife has driven the same
car for 20 years
wow they're cheap though they're like
they're like i'm i'm cheap and they're
cheap to me
i had a friend in high school a very
good friend at the time
and his family
they were wealthy for our neighborhood
like their house they had a movie
theater house and like girl i'll go with
you to your house i'm like what i've
never seen anything like that
i believe in the burbs like even having
a swimming pool was just yeah
like a luxury
and so i would like go to his house and
be like
like just yeah oh and like this wasn't
even the nice neighborhood yeah this was
like a wealthy neighborhood but not a
nice neighborhood and like
he would tell him i'm like how did your
family get so successful like how's your
dad so successful and he literally said
my dad's a penny pincher it's not that
he's like this insane businessman he was
smart with his money he invested wisely
we don't spend our money on luxury like
luxury
and now they're
that's that's how my dad is like we have
a movie theater house too that's how i
was like
so i was like that's what i don't know
that i mean
i have a freaking movie theater that's
when i'll know that i've made it no
because my dad um like we never i
remember like my friends all had cable
and i remember being so jealous i was
like my parents are richer than everyone
here we don't have [ __ ] cable like i
remember thinking this and i was like
why do we like we would always drive and
never fly and like we would never eat
out for like most of my child it's like
small things but they add up
um but now i'm kind of glad they did
that because it's like taught me to like
be cheaper you know what i mean like
it's taught me money skills sort of
i feel like until i started this podcast
please send a donation please please i
feel like i have like such like a
um
like we weren't wealthy by any means
but like
you know after my dad got like a good
job with multi i don't know none of you
guys probably know what that is it's a
uh
he's a cm and
you know we've got our house that we're
in now
i never they're like they're of course
there's things you want like but yes
they were really into like they would
give us whatever they could but yeah you
also had to earn your way yeah i don't
know like i just like i
feel like
i don't really
want like a house the movie theater like
yeah i'm saying like oh my gosh and do
you know you don't understand how much
work it is to maintain that house i
wouldn't even if i could afford it
i'm telling you a house that big is so
much worse so my parents have been a
two-story it's a
one two three
four five
it's a six bedroom house but it's not
like you wouldn't look at it and be like
oh it's like a six bedroom yeah yeah
whatever it's um
middle class like a middle-class
household that one you'd expect
especially middle-class italian
households yeah they got bougie things
in there they got like old clocks and
stuff yeah but um
like even my mother like
she
the amount of cleaning mm-hmm that it
takes for her to maintain yeah her house
our health because my my i mean anyone
who's italian i feel like you know your
the household is [ __ ] and span like
counter tops are clean like for
dirty for my mom is having like male
kind of like on like oh yeah
i don't know just
everything there's always lines in the
carpet like the couches are yeah
she keeps the house looking great and
it's a full-time job
full time i can imagine
oh my god like we um
my parents when we had friends over i
would always get so embarrassed because
they would put my friends to work like
i said like imagine like being like 12
and coming to my house and then my mom
being like it's chore day and like
making you do chores
like half the time you're there oh my
gosh okay what are people saying
um
a lot of people saying like
people are way too house-risked so
they're paying for houses to heat rooms
they never go in
yeah that's probably true california
refugees are pouring into my state i had
an opportunity to buy a rental property
where it started i really wish i had
because real estate's through the roof
people are leaving california right
right like my family's definitely
considered it because like in california
then i'm not gonna disclose like any
personal information but the amount of
money my dad makes at this point like we
moved to another state we
yeah yeah also like you know it's like
you're home there's california rich and
then there's like rich in other states
california rich is a different freaky
kind i have to say like i know a lot of
people that have insanely good jobs that
make a lot of money and they're barely
scraping by yeah that's insane to me
well it's like it's so weird because you
ever see those houses like texas versus
california but like okay do you want to
live in texas yeah i would
i'm from california
spoiled california is amazing like no
matter what anyone says like yes it's
overcrowded but california oh the
weather i was there for like three
months last year the weather's perfect
perfect
i know that it's gonna like now that i
don't live in california or that i went
to college in nevada like
it's gonna be so hard going back to
california because what i've heard from
people is once you leave going back is
like impossible because you're you
you're not used to you're used to having
more for your money
so going back like
subtracting like
or you get what i'm saying is a lot
harder like you can't go backwards once
you're once you're out you're out
because you're used to having that like
spending money and you wouldn't have
that if you're right and like to i feel
like it's so much easier to
move somewhere and like have more than
to move somewhere and be like well i'm
going to have less like i have to live
my life
differently and more frugal
um
but no california is the i
love california i don't think i could
live anywhere else honestly
that's uh do you think it's better um do
you think when you get married it's
about love
um i would say when you're young yes
when you're probably when you're older
it's not just about
yeah well i can say like now the
relationship i'm in like where we're at
is like we know the next step is like
more serious
and it's not just about love because
we're thinking realistically like
student debt
like what what is your career going to
be what is my career going to be like
how are we going to split bills like we
like i definitely want to be a mom
that's a big thing for me i want to have
kids i don't want to have kids any time
soon you know probably by the time i'm
like 30 hopefully i'll start having
children but like mm-hmm you know mm-hmm
and you guys have those like
conversations yeah yeah yeah when you're
younger it's easy to just be like oh my
god like fairy tale love story right but
then once you get older and you're like
okay well it's not all fairy tales
i told my dad that he could pick out my
husband really yeah
that's a smart guy that's what i told
him i'm like i clearly i'm not a great
picker so i'm an italian an italian
italian man will take care of you and he
will take care of you good in italian
they're they're a little old-fashioned
but they will take care of you
financially financially well i don't
really need to i mean i i do kind of
have to worry about that but i'm just in
a like a different position yeah i
understand i don't know for me it's more
of like i don't think about that now but
when i have children like i don't want i
want to be there for my kids i don't
want to have to hire help
oh do you want like your husband like
what percent of the bills do you want to
be responsible for that's a question
they always ask i don't i can't tell you
right now because like i don't really
like i'm too young to have even a
concept of like okay it would really be
honestly
but
if i'm pushing out the children like i'm
taking care of the children
like well granted the career i'm going
towards i can pick my pick and choose my
hours like i can work a couple hours a
day do a couple sessions a day
and like when my husband comes home and
then do those sessions make like 300
dollars whenever i'm charging hours
and
call it a day but like if i'm
when i first like children are young i
don't wanna work like i wanna be there
for my kids every second they need their
mom and like i grew up in that
environment where my mom was
the sole caretaker my dad was always
gone working
my
connection to my mom is so strong like
in that sense and i feel like
that is also like the italian way mm-hmm
and i want to have that you know like i
that that's not something that i'm
morally willing to give up like when my
children are i want to work i would like
to be a working mother when they are
ready and able for me to be a working
mother when they're young they need
their mother
so like how young like five and under um
i would say once they're like five once
they're in kindergarten i would like to
be working full time again in
kindergarten okay what how old is that i
don't even know four three four five
five six i don't know
they don't think you're young you're an
adult they all like in the manosphere
they really push like women getting
married younger because
you can kind of marry a richer guy the
younger you are ellie the [ __ ] party
yeah it smells
bro you don't you don't even understand
she like ruins my apartment it smells so
bad
she better not she's crazy
right here oh that's why i smell it
she's right here i was like oh gosh
oh my god
oh god
oh god
maybe we'll put ellie's crate in that
that room now that i moved i destroyed
my hallway too
yeah maybe we'll also like
get tangled up well i might i might put
my guitar stuff in there because like it
probably would make sense still
don't judge me here go ahead go ahead my
uh
um texas is the poverty highest poverty
child rate in the us other than west
virginia
my mother worked from home let's see
they want to see your tattoos
oh god she has so many she's a whole
sleeve
i got them all up here but i'll save
that for another day
woman the elbow boy
listen if you're not ready don't get it
i'm not i'm hurt like i have all my
hands like
i've got them all over but my elbow
humbled me greatly like i've never had i
feel like i'm a g with tattoos like i've
gotten my my stomach is done mm-hmm
like and anyone that gets tattoos will
tell you your stomach that [ __ ] is
painful and that was fine like i i could
take it
to an extent like i mean i wasn't like
whatever it wasn't like dying like
obviously like hurt a little bit my
elbow
i clenched my cheeks so hard that my ass
was sword for days
like there was a stress did you scream
no okay
okay you're not you're not you're tough
yeah but like holy [ __ ] i was like are
you done are you [ __ ] done yet
i had a stress ball and i squeezed that
[ __ ] so hard first of all i thought i
had carpal tunnel after second of all
the thing would not reinflate like it
was dead
it was done for like
i'm afraid of getting tattoos um tattoos
are addicting women okay it says women
marrying for love is one of the most
misleading statements what makes you
think the love of your life is defined
by hypergamous
requirements okay so he's saying
marrying for love is a misleading
statement what makes you think the lo
like who you fall in love so love with
is defined by
basically the best option that you can
get because if you didn't marry for love
it would kind of become like more of
like like before in the old days you
know your dad would like sell you for a
cow or something
so like
like it's kind of like hypergamy because
it's like
well he'd sell you for something because
they bought
or he would say like i can take care of
your daughter i have this skill or
whatever it is i feel like in general
like we're talking about women as a
whole uh-huh yeah like duh like
so i need to stop saying like i feel
like me too it's bad
the two of us uneducated um
but
we're educated okay we're getting our
masters yeah we're so smart
but um
like
i feel like
you always talk about with me
the biological side of it yes
so i feel like
you're gonna find the best mate like
that's what you always say and i feel
like that makes sense too yeah conscious
well i think men also want like everyone
wants to get the best mate they can i
don't think that's women alone like guys
want the hottest like most feminine like
whatever their requirements are like
everyone wants the best that they can
get well okay so i think that something
you and i have talked about a lot is
like how men fall in love with me i feel
like part of the reason that is because
of my upbringing
italian and i'm very motherly you're
also very supportive yeah because yeah
my the way that i am motherly like if
you're my man like i will cook for you
every night like i will i will take care
of you like in my way yeah i'm not gonna
like go be like crazy likes mm-hmm
i don't know like you know what i'm
saying but yeah if you're my man you're
good like i will take care of you like
whatever that takes and whatever your
love language is i'll make sure that
that's
done and received
i'm not a pushover by any means though
but like i really think that the way
that i'm super motherly that's what it
is yeah well i think um
i don't know you're also very supportive
because i can tell you're very
supportive with me and it's like nice to
have someone around like that like
supports my channel so much but also
like it's like it's easy when you
it's easy to support people that
are
genuinely talented i feel like
are you saying the men you dated weren't
well i'm not
live
oh my god untalented oh my god it says
your nana taught you well thank god for
italian women italian women are the best
this is whatever anyone said bro italian
women we are top tier and you guys can
cook too you guys you guys age a little
better you're a little tanner
like it's nobody's business like girl i
do not burn let me tell you i used to
play beach volleyball and i would be so
just
like my mother
i gave to my mom like my mom tans
beautifully
like yeah oh my god like it's amazing
and like my natural hair is curly it
hasn't been lately because like being
here i don't know what it is with the
water in london my hair does not curl
the same but my natural hair is really
curly
and
like i get that from my mom too and i'm
just like thank you for making me not
just like uh
no offense a plain like white [ __ ]
why'd you say no offense gabby
what are you doing you literally drop it
off of white's girl i'm like no it's
okay okay i don't care
no me and you we've talked about this we
have different styles but in my opinion
like i feel like you shouldn't dictate
yourself based on other people yeah like
no offense i'm not a tattoo person just
not my thing but but like you would
still get your tattoos regardless so who
cares what i think yeah literally like
yeah
like for example for christmas my
grandparents came over and i know like
she knows that i have all these tattoos
yeah she's disgusted by them but like
you know
italian grandma like what like yeah so
like one time i wore red lipstick around
my nona and
god bless this woman she is the most
incredible woman but old-fashioned
italian woman she's like you look like a
prostitute like that's what prostitutes
wore like your your grandfather red
lipstick yes wow and it was like a
brownish whatever
your grandfather is going to literally
death like
fall down and die when he sees you like
that i was like 17 at the time also yeah
i was like oh my god like lipstick
i saw some of the other outfits
oh my god
she saw my tattoos and she goes
um
are those permanent it's like
yeah they are she's like
oh oh
oh
and i was like i don't know it's
checking me out i
don't know what else to say right now
like
what oh my gosh my mom told me i i
wasn't even serious but i told her that
i was getting a tattoo and she said that
i
she would not pay for my college back
then
jokes on her i got my first tattoo when
i was 15 years old how
um a guy's garage
oh
yeah it was my first tattoo it's on my
side on this side and it's um
philippians 4 13.
philippians 4 13. yeah
okay so it's like a bible verse yeah
but it's like he did it really bad so it
healed super weird have you ever had a
tattoo that you hate
oh yeah i have a lot i have one right
here on my sternum that's supposed to be
like a snake wrapped around a rose
but
it's
bad like it doesn't look like it looks
like a gray blob i also have
well we won't talk about those ones
but um this one i hate these angel wings
this is one of the first ones i got i
hate this one
why
i don't even like flying in the air i
don't like
i don't know like
that was why i never got one was because
i was like i just feel like i'm gonna
regret it later you know though it's
like
i don't really care for me like my
tattoos it's like a mole like if you
have like a mole that you have had your
whole life you don't know you don't
notice it when you look in the mirror
like i don't notice my tattoos when i
look at me like i'll be like hey that's
sexy like that's sick but like i don't
ever look at it and be like oh
disgusting you know it's just a part of
my body what
oh they said get on kevin samuels live i
don't think he's live right now guys
try his instagram we'll see
you don't know who kevin samuels is i
don't i'm that part of the youtube what
did she say
um
okay kevin
i don't think he's live
no he's not live
oh my gosh i should do smash or pass
with you with manosphere man because you
don't know any of them
um
okay
guys who should she smash or pass put it
in the chat i'll show it on the
screen but like respectfully though yeah
very respectful smasher packs like don't
give me no like
like obvious like
um
you know what i'm saying
does she think that
um he's not live when he's live
i don't know i've called into a show
before i don't
i don't know what i would call in for
pearl don't do this why not i don't care
what the
he won't be
live until
wait pearl don't do what what are you
doing
the smasher pass i don't care
um
okay mediocre tutorials and reviews
um
choose instagram
sorry
hey
i'm doing this but like i don't want to
pay for drinks
you know that's the thing in the uk like
men don't like or like bartenders
usually will just give you free drinks
like here they do not get free drinks
out
they are very stingy
in the bar oh i don't i like haven't i
haven't gone to bars since like college
um okay
okay this is mediocre tutorials and
reviews
wait i have to smash your path yeah
okay well here's the thing i'm super
picky so that's okay if it was like like
in general like yeah he's attractive
like he's obviously not you could just
not be your type it's okay it's just not
my type
i have one type and that's it and like i
don't strengthen that type
okay okay so he would pass for you no
yes yes okay i would smash
okay wait
um okay let's see nothing he's an
attractive man just
super picky i did this last time
everyone's cup of tea like that's fine
yeah i did this last time with torsha
first i like to do it with girls it's
fun
you guys could send your instagrams in
if you want
all right myron
this guy smash your pass
how tall is he it's like 6'3
so here's the only thing is well after
seeing that picture absolutely not which
one
this one
i know i hate it when guys have pictures
like this i'm like you that the first
picture yes you look like a very
respectful man but why are you exposing
yourself like in that picture like
[Music]
you don't see me out here posting bikini
pictures partially because i'm not
bikini body ready but also like come on
like have some self-respect
perspective um just kidding
wallace from
fresh and fit okay i don't like any of
the fresh guys i've seen like very
minimal stuff on tape talk and they are
all misogynists and i'm good so past you
don't even show um okay i don't like men
that think okay
all right
this guy i did the video with him fredo
bang
really
yes i love it
[Music]
okay um
see pearl no shade is your guest taller
than you it's not shade yeah she's
talking to me
yeah
not my type is an excuse
no it's not an excuse at all like look
all these men have been attractive
uh tommy so do mine but that's not like
objectively yes subjectively it's not
what i'm into there's nothing wrong with
that at all
i don't know
tommy sotomayor's instagram i don't
think this is it because he's only got
600 followers
um
i'm glad i can't see because if someone
says something insulting to me i'm gonna
kill myself
pearl is only doing this so she can
present black men oh my gosh this guy is
so weird he always comments like it's
the weirdest [ __ ] pearl's only doing
this
so she can present black men to
normalize white women dating black men
which is totally off limits and
disrespectful
sir do you know what that gets you
i wish i could like not care but like
really oh thank you for the super chat
sorry sorry i gotta thank you so much
for the super chat ah yay five dollar
donation sorry keep going sorry keep
going keep going um
no yeah that's why i don't like
personally like i'll do it for you
because i love you
i don't do the internet because people
are really mean and people are so mean
people like someone was like one big
thing about me and i'm gonna go home and
i'm gonna think about it for three years
really oh yeah i'm super soft like
there's no way i could be on the
internet
that's just not i'm not built for it i'm
too mentally ill
the
is this your instagram sir
is this brandon fraser is that
brandon
uh i love supportive men
what about tom holland
um are you [ __ ] lying to me right now
i okay
listen to me listen to me now and i am
so passionate about this okay i
when i was
three and spider-man came out toby
maguire one of the first things i ever
said it was a full sentence was i'm
going to marry toby maguire because i
was obsessed with spider-man anyone that
puts on a spider-man costume
they can get it
get it like i don't care like toby
mcguire he's so unattractive fit like
objectively but like subjectively like
i'm so attracted to him because he's i
grew up with like obsessed with
spider-man so he could [ __ ] like
smash smash
he's shorter than you
smash put on that spider-man suit we get
us some role play baby yes oh my god
andrew tate this
guy is he a viewer no just so he's
famous
i don't see okay here's the thing guys
that are like okay so this is what i
think when i see pictures of guys like
this they're like hey bro
take a flick bro like can you take a
picture of me and this is like sauna bro
like start off i'm like okay
i actually think he's better looking in
videos to be honest
like again objectively but if i super
attractive but if i saw like let's see
what picture do i hate athletes like
they all have pictures taken of them
like working out or something but that's
like their job like yeah like you know
to me that's attractive but like guys
that just are like yo bro
you take a picture of me for the grand
like no that's cringey to me that's all
i can think about that's like when you
watch a show and like you should can
tell that they're acting and um
that's how i feel
about
like if you're taking a picture and it's
like a group picture or you're taking a
picture for like a job or something like
but if when a guy is like hey bro
there's just something about it's like
girly almost
and maybe it's just like my like
internalized like
feeling of like i need i like
masculinity like i don't if i want a man
i want a man you know and to me that's
like
i don't know
kind of girly girly yeah personally
nothing wrong with it though what is the
pregame too notice the main topic it's
not really a topic we're just farting
again we're just testing
oh god i don't know
she's do you hear her snoring
that's a stinky beat i'm nervous i'm
nervous
it's okay it wasn't that bad the first
one was oh my god that smells so i was
like i didn't smell it at first but then
you were like oh my god i was like
wait let me just check something i
didn't i don't like to like i'm gonna
see when they're gonna get here
[Music]
oh my gosh
you remember this guy he was so hot
remember
no okay well
hey
um
[Music]
let me see when
i'm not really in a rush but don't most
of the bars close at like two
eleven
wait what
oh they close at eleven what time is it
ten almost
we're [ __ ]
are some that are open but like most of
them close at 11.
oh my gosh
um
see and like this is the thing every
time we go to do something we don't
leave until like 11. i know it's like
our problem but like i'm saying today
wasn't our fault but i would have told
them to hurry if i knew everything
closed at 11. yeah
we're in london shouldn't ship be open
till like five in the morning
um i don't really hear
ellie snoring
that's good um
italian lady listen i want a man also
italian lady anyone in a spiderman
costume
the guys are going to watch the stream
put on a spiderman costume and ask you
like i haven't
had like a lot of fantasies like that
but i have a sexual fantasy
about spiderman and i have dreams about
it and i wake up like
tj's gonna like pick you up from the
airport oh no he knows like spider-man
kisses like you know the upside down oh
my god
those get me going
i'm like
like um just you know it's just like a
childhood thing that i've always been
like i was in love with spiderman i
almost got a spiderman tattoo that's how
obsessed with spiderman i am like when i
watch the tom holland no or the
spiderman no way home
i cried
multiple times when
i'm not an andrew garfield fan
genuine well now i am more so
what after you saw him in spiderman do i
have anything i'm kind of like that with
um police uniforms a little bit
and like army like i just like like
like a man that can like protect me a
little bit
i know
are the guys in the uk better than the
us
my experience i've only
i've really only gone on dates with one
other guy from the uk
and he
did not oh my gosh i need i'm gonna tell
this story i'm live okay guys
so
right after i got out of my last
relationship okay
i me i well okay me and my last
boyfriend broke up a couple times
throughout the year
okay like on and off on and off one time
we broke up was for about like three
weeks i would say right before i came
here because he was like i don't want to
do distance i said okay
during this time i met a guy off of
hinge from the uk
i liked him whatever you know but we
kind of had like a connection but then
when my boyfriend wanted to get back
together i just ghosted him for like
three months okay
you know didn't talk to him then me and
my boyfriend break up again
in
i don't know like december and like a
couple months later and i'm like hey are
you still single by chance you know
i liked him you know but i didn't know
him well enough to like whatever
anyways this man
starts taking me on dates it's like
going well okay
and i like him whatever
but he's like super like he comes down
so strong and i've never i'm like not
used to like
guys being in love with me that fast
well just like like oh i want to date
you this is where like i see where it's
going i'm very marriage minded i'm like
okay like
cool you know like that's kind of what
i'm looking for but it just makes you
wonder like are you doing this to every
[ __ ] you're like are you doing this to
every [ __ ] and i'm like there has to be
a catch right because he's super wealthy
right super like so i mean like is he
lying about the wealth whatever like
there's be a catch he's too perfect he's
like
you know he's not like hot but he's cute
enough tall enough right taller than me
right has a lot of money right like
super successful
um
and and he he's um
and he's like cool you know super
helpful super nice i'm like what is the
catch and about a couple dates in this
man tells me
okay
i
have two kids
and two that i returned
he didn't say returned but this didn't
tell you this part
bro bro okay okay bro
bro bro no
no no so he what he does okay let me let
me tell you
bro bro you don't even understand no no
no no no no
it's never enough but i don't what do
you no it's like there had to be a catch
if that was it but i was like what is
the catch
i
i don't i don't have kids i don't feel
like i should have to date somebody with
children like i don't know what that's
not what you're no no i don't like
that's just i would take a guy with less
money less everything no kids if you are
a man with kids
disclose that information before the
date before we don't want to be
a lot of us we don't want to be stepmoms
and if you think oh well she's going to
fall in love with me and want to be like
us no that's not how no that's
information you just closed before
bro
bro
okay okay okay let me just say this
unless you're just looking to like [ __ ]
her and never speak to her again which i
understand i understand i did like but
like other than that
bro
and like he was so intentional with
everything so it wasn't like we were
just trying to hook up like he was very
much like i want to date you you know
and
and he was like he watched
this is part of the story i'm gonna tell
you
okay so
so
i
he we're having a movie night right at
my apartment and he puts on the holiday
oh i love that okay now okay do you
remember the scene in the movie
yes
where where the the man the man um
talks about
how
the man talks about how um
like he has kids like he's on the phone
outside and she's like that's weird and
she's like who are you talking to yeah
and cameron diaz and he's like oh i have
two daughters
and she's like mad yeah and he looks at
me and he says would you be mad if that
happened and i'm like
bro yes and i'm
yeah
like i would absolutely i would be
pissed you know that he has taken a
[ __ ] to watch
[Laughter]
no okay i don't i don't know okay but
okay at this point guys at this point
this man is watching my dogs i'm going
back to the u.s and he's watching my dog
for three weeks while i go back
up
and so i'm like this is a bombshell he
drops this bomb okay and not only did he
have two kids he had two kids that he
adopted
and sent back
that stayed with him for like three or
four years him and this girl broke up
and they sent them
back you know what
it's not funny it's not funny at all bro
like
people really like to blow my mind like
that's [ __ ] up i'm like how do you get
a pro okay how do you get approved for
children
i don't i don't know how it works i
can't speak
uh i don't mind blowing
i don't know what was going on i know
about the two the two other children
part
um
i didn't tell you that oh my gosh so
then like and i kind of liked him you
know like i
i never like did anything with him you
know what i mean and like like
i liked him enough to like you know but
we'd only known each other for a little
bit but then he dropped this bomb on me
i'm going back to the u.s like the next
day
and
on top of that
like
oh my god and on top of that like
you're watching my dog for two weeks
which he offered which i wouldn't have
like accepted it
if i knew it was like you didn't know
anyone else out here and who else was
gonna watch what i would i'm resourceful
i would have figured it out if he didn't
drop this bomb on me the date like it
was like a day or two before i'm
supposed to leave and i'm just like
oh my god this is too like one it was
already moving like way faster than i
wanted it to right oh my god
that was
no wait okay can i just say like when
she first told me that she was gonna uh
go on a date with this guy i was like
make sure he's not a murderer bro
yeah i
i mean he wasn't a murderer but i
i could not the second and when i broke
i broke it off with him like
because i had to i had to think about it
like at first i'm a thinker so i was
like i'm gonna think about this over
break after so i get my dog back um
and
and i'm like look
i
so i break it off with him right and
this man like is not leaving my
apartment like he i'm like okay i'm
gonna order like pizza now he's just
like and i think he's mad because maybe
like he never slept with me
you know so maybe he's like i put all
this like time and energy into this girl
okay yeah
and like maybe he's like hoping i'm like
oh no like
oh no the door like
oh no like
the door is the door like and he's just
like sitting there and i'm like
like i'm like too nice to the point
where i'm just like
i swear to god you stayed for like an
hour and a half
and i'm just like a knife would get
pulled out at that point if it were me
and you know how it is like when you
don't know someone well and you're a
girl and something gets weird like
your mind is like oh my god oh my god
like is anything gonna nothing happened
but i mean like i feel personally like
i'm very possessive of my space like my
home like that's my safe space like
so i feel like at that point i would be
like
yelling screaming get the [ __ ] out like
freaking out like you know you don't
want to like provoke why date a guy with
kids i didn't know
like if i knew he had kids like the
first date i wouldn't have had gone on a
second date with him i had a similar
situation like i was with a guy for
almost over a year and i found out that
he had a
child in chicago my older sister she
dated a guy
they were living together they were like
practically engaged he was about to
propose to her she gave up playing
professional volleyball overseas
she and she this my sister was a amazing
volleyball player like i'm talking
freshman of the year at washington state
played in hawaii your little sister my
older sister your older sister okay not
blood related but my older sister yeah
played in hawaii and then also played at
idaho gave up playing professional
volleyball for this guy
and
he had two children also in
chicago yeah
i men are this is the second time i've
been bamboozled with children okay the
first time the first time i was
bamboozled with kids bro the first time
i stayed i was very embarrassing i like
i should not have you told me such a
good sob story
let me know
oh my gosh
the first time the first time i was i'm
like i'm just tired just tell me
if you have children up front kids
no it's not like he learned his lesson
with the next [ __ ] that's all i have to
say
that's all i have to say
not naming names oh my god no not like
you learn his lesson with the negative h
oh my god no the first um
the first the first guy i'm not going to
name names but the first guy that
bamboozled children i asked him the day
the night i met him she was you know a
little bit more well-known i'm like
do you do you have a daughter
and like at that point
he's like no no i don't i'm like oh okay
i thought i saw something online that
you did but maybe i didn't you know
[Music]
look at even your girl gets bamboozled
sometimes
anyways i just thought that no meant no
like i don't i didn't know it meant yet
no means no
that's what that's what i thought
as much as what as one shot
anyways so what did i do i i'm like
alright cool whatever
i keep like hanging out with him getting
to know him better
and
my
like we kind of stopped talking for a
second and my friend
that was a dude like we hung out and
we're like no he has kids
and i'm like
i'm like okay does he but whatever like
we kind of like fizzled out for a second
so i was like okay whatever whatever
um then then and i'm like does he and i
looked it online
and then like i talked to him again
right i'm like do you do you have
children there's this article that says
you have kids
and he's like
no
i don't
and i'm like
okay well why would that doesn't make
sense like what no i'm kind of gullible
like let's let's just like i'm very
global
yeah no i'm so global and so then he's
like
um
no like they just um it's like my nieces
and nephews they just assumed it was my
kids but like some some something that
made sense to me at the time yeah i was
like oh
so he lied yeah
lovely
the [ __ ]
so then
then i tell my friend emily this and my
friend emily she's not
she's like you like if i told you that
you would be like
like you would be searching the internet
for something right
as
some girls
well also i've had experience with
people that
i don't you know most people i know tell
the truth about their children you know
that's your prerogative that's that's
you know that's your experience in life
oh look you asked if he had a daughter
he never said anything about sons it
turns out he had both actually
but
anyways so he um
[Music]
anyway so my so my friend um so it sends
me a screenshot of a picture of him
holding the kid right after it was born
saying like when you like something but
you a dad now
and so i just sent him the screenshot
i'm like sir
sir
probably the only photo he has with his
children like sorry to say i don't like
it i'm sorry i don't know i don't know
what i don't know what happened with
that then he gave me the sob story oh my
gosh they always have a sob story
it's called
um
[Music]
okay
[Music]
i feel that
i was thinking about stopping my mind
and grabbing my umbrella too because i
thought it was going to rain later
[Music]
i
do but it's like super mini it's like
really like literally can only fit like
your card in it i have a mini black
purse too okay
does it fit around your wrist no you can
put it around your waist like you can
put it like if it's around mine so
okay can i use it yeah of course
yeah no for sure i wonder how many tick
tocks posted ever okay just let me know
when you're like close and we can meet
up um
because i just i just have to stop my
flat and grab it but like no it'll fit
around you perfectly it's super cute um
you can put your like phone in it
i have one too she can try to first well
pearl has one so you can try pearls and
if not then we can stop at my place
[Music]
women always have pity parties it's not
a it's not a pity party that happened
like
i don't know
oh [ __ ] i don't feel bad
what's mine is yours baby
mine is yours all right get get back
safe don't get like stolen or anything
um
sorry guys for that
wait wait pearl you have kids dude guy
jedi jedi hand wave i do not have
children pearl you do not have children
oh my god
i would call the world gullible your
ceiling oh my god absolutely i just
moved this couch back
so it's like a little bit
this can only go so far yeah there you
go oh my god this looks so good
didn't it
i think the cords are going to be an
issue but that's the list
are you kidding me bro i don't know how
because i need this space
because like the camera has to be here
and not have the lighting to be more
like
does this feel like it's on you no i
think the lighting is good okay
um
oh my gosh what advice what advice do
you have for a 22 year old male 1
um my advice for you is
genuinely like i'm being so serious
humor like you can make a girl laugh
that'll get you everywhere if what like
what are you looking for what was this
what was this question like advice is a
22 year old like
i need more specifics yeah what are you
what are you looking to achieve yeah
what are you doing what is your goal
like are you looking to just [ __ ] some
[ __ ] looking for like a wife like i
would say if you're looking to hook up
be as direct as possible
also could get you anywhere but like but
not like [ __ ] confidence no if you
get rejected it's all about how you
respond yes there is there are we we've
been talking about this there are guys
that we have said no to and changed our
mind later because of how they responded
yes or no
okay
okay first of all my ex that i was with
for like two years
similar situation but the man that i'm
with now
for a year
he was trying to get a date with me and
i was not interested because he's
shorter than me technically i'm six
three he's six too
and i was not interested like he was an
attractive man but like i just typically
am attracted to men that are bigger than
me because like i'm a big i'm a tall big
[ __ ] like i want a man that's like
bigger than me and
i finally was like okay like gave in and
was like we can hang out
we've been together ever since
persistence but like respectful
persistence yeah but it's like it almost
plants a seed when you know they're
attracted to you or it's like i don't
know it makes you a little more
attracted to them like knowing you know
what you want and men that know what
they want that is very attractive yeah
very attractive like my man now he had
sent his family like pictures of me and
like this is my he manifested this [ __ ]
he manifested this because he was like
hold on is brad calling you yeah
is she calling you or
hello
hello
hey
do you have a foldy umbrella
oh sorry are you talking about it i was
i thought you talked to her do you have
a foldy umbrella no she does not i do
though but like it's in my apartment
ah
is this the friend you said was for the
streets no
i
no just date another girl and let that
girl see her
that's true do you think jealousy works
no really for me i think it does but
also i've been cheated on a lot so
jealousy for me is not a thing that
works like if if i have to feel like
jealous around you i want nothing to do
with you have you ever taken back a
cheater
um yeah but also when i was a lot
younger and super emotionally like yeah
[ __ ] up
yeah i've been with a cheater i've been
with a man that used to [ __ ] rape me
while i was sleeping i told you this
sorry i digress not like a story i'm
going to share but
you know when you're younger and you're
deaf like you don't have a strong like
family
when things are [ __ ] up at home you
look for affection elsewhere or love
elsewhere and that's what i did so i
would have yeah i've been a man that
cheated on me but when i was a kid yeah
you're just like a teenager
not as an adult [ __ ] now
um
uh what's the oldest you would date
i
don't want to say that i'd put a cap on
it but like
okay for me
like i want a man that can
run and play with my children i think
it's also about like health
i'm talking about that's the problem
with age gap is like if i date someone
20 years older than me when i'm 40 he's
gonna be 60 that's like very different
yeah and like i don't i can't say
genuinely like i've never been in a
serious relationship with anyone that's
significantly older than me
but
i
don't
judge people
that are with people that are much older
than them or i you know but just in
general what's the cap for you um
currently i cur it's like a serious
relationship like just hooking up yeah
no serious but serious relationship i
would say 30. 30 30. well you're 22. so
that's not too bad years i think i think
eight to ten years would be my cap
personally uh my cap
i'm 25 so
35
the i would say 40 maybe like i
mean it all depends on the guy right i
think guys
the right guy makes you break like what
do they call it um girls breakout rules
for alpha that's like alphas that's one
of the like like girls have rules until
they meet the right guy so but i mean i
think ideally 10 years or less but like
15 isn't bad either to be honest 20 is
where i'm like i'm thinking about like
my grandparents
and
my grandfather is like four years older
than my grandmother i think five is like
ideal
like at their age
that feels like such a big gap because
one is so close to 90 and one is just
starting their 80s kind like in the
middle of their 80s kind of like when
you think when i think of that that
makes me be more like i would rather
have someone closer to my age you know
yeah but also it's different like like
for men than women because women like we
can only reproduce to a certain point
and then like men they can just
yeah well that's that's the other thing
is because money isn't as like big of a
thing for me i think i'd rather have
someone i could be like
around for a while you know because i
like i understand i'm gonna
um
be with that person hopefully until
you're like 80 right oh that's the goal
yeah i mean i see my parents and my
grandparents and like there was one
christmas like i will talk about
specifically that my nona something
happened and
she fell or i can't even really remember
it's a couple years back and she was in
the hospital and it was like not a great
situation and my grandfather called my
mom and he could not even talk like he
was so distraught that my grandfather or
my gran the mynona was ill he couldn't
even he like
like like couldn't speak
and he's like
one of the things he said to my mom was
like i don't know what to do without her
you know what i'm saying like yeah
that's what that's like that's like the
type of love you want that's yeah that's
what i strive for because that's i know
that the same thing would it would be
with my mom and my dad like my parents
have been together for 25 years
and it hasn't been easy yeah well that's
the thing i think people think like
you're gonna feel love your entire
marriage i don't think that's true like
my parents were happier than most of my
friends and there were still years where
they really didn't like each other that
much talk about my parents honestly but
we went through rough patches yeah sure
yeah
but it's kind of like just like being
because it goes back to work ethic too
because relationships are working you
have to be willing to like put in the
work to work it out it also depends on
like my dad is the hardest worker i've
ever met my life my dad is my superhero
like if i can say anything
that man has came from nothing like i'm
talking came from nothing and worked his
ass off to be where he is so has this
have his siblings they've come from a
shitty situation and made a lot of
themselves
but you know my dad was taking care of
his siblings from the age of like 11
like yeah like
been on his own forever like the reason
he stopped playing college basketball is
because he had to work like he had to
pay bills and support his siblings like
he had a
rough life and he made
his way for himself and i that is
something that i think that i feel like
i need in a man like that is that hard
of a worker of mine as my dad but then
it's also like growing up i don't
remember my dad around a lot because he
was always working well that's that's
what i always talk about like there's a
cost to everything everything and that's
what i say i did not really have a
relationship with my dad until i was
like 16 15. and i i look up to my dad so
much now like you hear me talk about it
right like i i look up to him so much if
i need advice on something like my dad
is where i go
but um
yeah i really didn't see him much before
like he'd be gone for like a month at a
time in india like building his business
wow like he my dad worked like 80 hours
a week my whole life see i feel like
that's similar to my situation because
my dad he was in construction and he
would be traveling for projects so it
was kind of just my mom my grandparents
would help out a lot but like
you know like similar like mm-hmm i just
like i remember there's i have like
memories where my dad is there
honestly i've locked out a lot of my
childhood i hate to say it but it's true
i don't remember a lot of my childhood
because of certain things like when you
have gone through trauma there is a
protection barrier that you put up for
yourself and it's like you block out a
lot of memories and so my brain has done
that but like most of my memories are
with my mother like but i but the thing
that sucks is like the reason i had
those memories is because of my dad
working so hard that my mom could be
home
well you can't because you can't have
everything you can't like you everything
is a trade-off and that was the
trade-off your mom got to be home all
the time but then your dad wasn't and
it's kind of
well we had nannies so it wasn't
though the trade-off over them was
having 10 kids
[Laughter]
they they can't
they can't even but like for me like
even it's hard now seeing my dad working
like
he's 53
and you know
my dad deals with his disease and
seeing him work still is like
it breaks my heart i'm like yeah i wish
that you could just
enjoy the rest of your life and not just
be working to support like your family
because that's all he's ever done his
whole life support his family but it's
like those traits like in my that i see
in my dad
is like i am so like i want that in a
partner
i'm so attracted to that like when a guy
that just is like passionate about
something and works hard like and
they always say it's about money and i
say if someone won the lottery they
would not be attractive yeah the money
alone does not make them attractive it's
the drive the work ethic the ambition
that is what we're attracted to
personally with my dad my dad knows
something about everything like you
could put that man on jeopardy and he
would win like he is the most
intelligent and he is a fixer like
everything in my house pretty much that
you see my dad built my dad literally
helped build our house he's interested
yeah yeah i had my furniture in my room
my dad built like he's a craftsman he's
talented like he's a fixer if i tell my
dad like oh this is wrong with my
computer oh my god's the same way yeah
sit there if he doesn't know until he
fixes it for him to say like i don't
know it's like not something yeah yeah
yeah like for that that trait
specifically for me
that's what i want to partner because
that's what my dad showed me yeah and i
love that that's such like a you just
feel so comforted like so taken care of
yeah
no and that's
that's yeah i know exactly what you're
talking about but the problem is what
not having i feel like not
having
my dad around like you remember i told
you the coach yeah like what happened
with me yeah because um
i feel like that situation
where i got like i got so close to that
coach is kind of because my dad was
working all the time to be honest
um like luckily nothing really like
happened with it but
um
but
let me look at the comments hold on
is that this and don't
have a witness a good hard way
um
[Music]
okay
marcus if you're rude i'm going to put
you in a timeout
why what are you saying it was just
something
it's
what's about me
well do you want do you want me to tell
you no was it gonna say something about
how i'm fat oh no oh no it wasn't about
that okay well then yeah it was it was
just he said um do you want to know no i
don't okay okay
no no okay it's fine
one hates you to
cry
no um what i was gonna say though is the
coach like because i was in i'm gonna
just tell them i was in a situation
where a coach like hit on me when i was
like pretty young
and um
like i didn't do anything with them at
all but like i feel like i was so
heartbroken because i looked at that
like coach kind of like a dad when my
dad wasn't around and it just kind of
like
i don't know it like sucked because it
was like i got so close with this coach
thinking he was like
you know a guy i could look up to and
then he tries to sleep with me and i was
like literally heartbroken when that
happened
like literally heartbroken
um
you can have freedom of speech but i can
also have the freedom to block you
that's what the guy said he's like
it's like freedom of speech i just want
to know marcus like clearly she knows
you why are you so angry like i pray for
you whenever you're going through i feel
like uh
you know
if that you're this it wasn't his wasn't
too bad i just was like yeah i don't it
was driving towards me clearly
would any of you teachers had a chance
um
okay
one
also okay okay okay
hey what were we talking about have i
feel like there's a lot when you're
young okay i feel like
men um
how do i put this like it's kind of
weird the things like older guys say to
you when you're like 14 or 15 but you
don't realize how weird it is until
you're older have you ever had that
experience like
i'm not even talking about like the ones
that straight out are creepy but just
like i don't even know like looks or
like subtle flirting or like
inappropriate topics when you're
underage and then you get older and
you're like what the [ __ ]
like i don't want to talk about like my
experience from when i was oh yeah
in middle school yeah
i definitely
noticed such a difference from when i
was underage to now about the men that
would hit on me
the different like
i i'll say this the guy that i lost my
virginity was 24.
he knew how old i was he didn't care
damn he didn't give a [ __ ] that's so
like well and it's so weird when you get
older when like i remember guys being
like oh i don't care when you're like 16
15. like one time i said oh i'm 17. and
this guy was like the age of consent in
ohio is 16 and i'm like
sir
it's like messed up there's a lot of
pedophilia that goes on with with like
for me like i have looked like a woman
since i was like 15 like 14 yeah
i was tall
i had boobs like i developed quickly
and
but like the fact that i was under age
like really attracted a lot of men
which is looking back terrifies me well
and that's
like i know men like biologically are
like
predisposit like they're supposed to
like biologically they tend to like
younger women i understand that but i'm
like guys there's a certain age where
it's just not fair because mentally you
are not like developed
like i the my decision-making skills are
like 14 15 16 like you're a different
person
about decision making skills all my
decision making skills were emotional
irrational like i made the worst choices
and decisions was because i had no
self-worth because i was hurt
and like i was a lost little kid
like i had no decision making skills i
still don't
i do more now but like when i was a kid
no i mean the worst decisions
thank you for the donation um i'll put
you on the screen hard-working men are
still appreciated here in italy i have a
female supervisor who married a man with
blue collar
[Music]
yeah buzz it press four and then the
bell four in the bell
four in the bell yeah
okay
sorry
live this is my british accent
your friends coming over
we have friends coming over
[Music]
any of you that are mean in the comments
check yourself and find jesus because
that you know
it's a reflection of you
the the hate you give the hate that you
put onto people is a reflection of
yourself so please
respectfully
thank you
it's been nice
okay this is the one place i don't want
you running okay this is the one
i don't think there's anything crazy hi
pearl hardworking men are so appreciated
yeah italy thank you
my people piedmonte
that's where i'm from uh
austin
baby what are you
oh you just opened the door it's open
it's open
okay
okay
guys we might have to end this soon
oh i just saw your
oh my god i knew she was i was just
trying to she's it's okay it's okay i
was just trying to get her like i was
literally just trying to grasp
are you getting chillier yeah
i was just testing
it wait how are you so look i'll show
you like on the mic yeah yeah so you
just sit there and talk into the mic so
then this is on youtube sort of hello
and then
youtube right now
it's not like it's it's chill sometimes
i go live and like
i like abuse my lives like i just like
one time i rap them alive
[Music]
oh you probably need to get like
something to hide all the wires and
stuff
[Music]
actually i want to test the other mic so
go sit over there
okay could i get a cupboard
yeah i'm just gonna bring these over
here oh my god you've got twix can i
have one of course you can make are you
trying to test this last one
um
okay
does it actually be good to test with
four i'm just want to see
i don't care no
um
okay okay
yeah hold on
should i do hair upper hair now okay i
want to see what let's see
okay okay first of all you can't look
weird
probably let me look okay
can i spit a little no i'm sorry i don't
like that
okay
oh
okay
[Music]
guys tell me how this sounds
okay talking to the mic just tell me all
right just say so everyone
ashley and i just sprinted for a bus
because it was two minutes away and then
we ended up having to spread for another
bus once we got to our location because
brit and g want to come back here
okay guys how do we sound in the chat
um
sounds good yeah
yeah you don't know how hard it worked
to get these freaking mics to work oh my
god please say yes
oh yeah yes
yes
[Music]
oh my god this this man
sounds pretty
[Music]
hello mic check one two one here
coming in july from girls free games
sorry am i gonna get soon
[Music]
[Music]
yeah all these um what are the circle
circle light things called again
yes
but i like the pink ones
okay
everyone say your names and your
relationship status
that's the one no
you can say it's complicated
my name is ashlynn and i'm in love
my name is pearl and i'm single
what are the rules about yelling near
the mics do it i think it's it i guess
we'll find out if it's really loud if
it's i think it's okay if it's bad guys
let me know but i think it's okay my
name is gabrielle
gabby will do
um complicated complicated but mostly
more taken than that
yeah i'd agree with that for you yeah um
i'm eileen
[Music]
would you say you're more single or more
complicated
um okay wait
the levels are off because
they're not close enough to their mics
so the feed is coming collective
i just don't want to like my big ass
head to like that is that better here
bring your mic closer and then scoot in
closer
[Music]
all right guys how does this sound
because i can turn up the volume and see
like if it'll pick us up a little better
[Music]
it wasn't like a hate comment it wasn't
it wasn't
you know
um we need that i think it just has to
be like really close to you otherwise it
takes the collective like that
i think only pearl has good volume well
that's because this is a different mic
than them
it's actually not i want to get rid of
this one
it's just a different type of mic
um
only okay
guys let me know in the chat how it's
going
okay wait let me hear this is gonna echo
because i'm gonna listen
um
i think
only pearl has good volume well that's
because this is a different mic than
them uh
[Music]
[Applause]
i think it might just have to be close
going okay it works it's going
the ladies sound like their mics are off
okay i can turn up the volume
what is what are the rules among cussing
in this i don't care
i've been trying
but
[Music]
okay wait um so you're pretty close to
yours so i'm trying to figure out
what the problem is
the voice
how do you processing well i don't think
[Music]
[Music]
my grandma's older sister but like
for me it's like no definitely like
that's terrible but it's like she hasn't
even known my name for the past like
five years so it's like what is that
your cup no that's just water um
[Music]
[Music]
thank you for helping me this is kind of
fun no it's really fun
we've been doing this for a while really
yeah we're sitting here on live chat
yeah we got some donations really
um did anyone pay for feet pics here
[Music]
but he didn't want next speed he wanted
like athletes like ugly
stretch
bigger but like make sure i stretch
though
i would make like a face like
like a big marking like on a
paper saying like this is one inch
whatever because you'd be like oh i want
it to be bigger like to like make them
bigger like stretch okay
a measurement and like would try to make
like lift my foot off the floor and like
try to make it look like it wasn't i'd
be like oh no really like
[Music]
but also like if she were to do that
then she'd give up her address to him
you don't have to return oh oh guess not
i have some shoes
[Music]
[Music]
apple juice it helps a lot it's okay
um i'm probably not going to drink
anymore because i drink water so your
core
is good
[Applause]
can i touch them
there we go
[Music]
[Music]
twice
[Music]
i'm just
yeah stop talking
[Music]
okay we'll try it and just see
oh my god look it we're hot
donate if you think that
they're sexy
um my venmo at is eileen 32
e-i-l-e-e-n-s-h-i
32
that's a 3-2
people are watching 22.
the 22 of you that are watching i'm
gonna also go back again
okay
no it's just like a test i was just
curious to see if this would work
the first time i've checked in your
channel and seen me dress up damn
that's so true
um
okay
[Music]
okay we were talking about earlier do
you guys prefer nice guys or do you
prefer like [ __ ] boys or do you think
there's a middle ground
situation yeah i think middle ground is
fun though because [ __ ] boys are too
like
flaky you know and it's like they think
that they're like oh like such a great
hit or whatever you know what i mean
and then they act like it even though
they're not even that great
i don't know exactly and what about nice
guys
they're just too nice
but like in the right situation
but like do you want someone that you
can walk all over
see that's the problem now
my man like i'm walking all over him
like he's a normal man
in this sector of youtube they say women
do [ __ ] tests which is like basically
where they like i'm gonna butcher it
because this is like a dude thing but
talk about this on the train yeah it's
like basically and butchering guys i
know in the comments you're gonna roast
me for butchering this but i'm telling
you not i'm going to butcher it so it's
basically like when a girl
kind of just like does something to you
to see how you react
yeah and like it's not conscious but
it's like kind of like making fun of
them a little bit to see if they get
like butt hurt or if they like kind of
give it back to you
i
just to make fun of them
you know
but i always think that nice guys are
like
they're not actually nice they're always
like pushovers it's not like an actual
you know what i mean yeah for sure
what do you think
[Music]
i only have a comment on the nice slash
fuckboy thing because i think it does
definitely depend on situation
but i feel like with like the [ __ ] test
a lot of that is just like
flirtation is most of the time banter
yeah so if you're gonna go up to a guy
and like roast him a little bit or say
something he's automatically like
offended or sensitive that's just a turn
off because i want to banter with you
and like if you're if you're confident
and comfortable in who you are then
you're not going to be like
freaked out if i make a comment about
something you know
so one thing that we talked about before
was like
uh like there's nice guys but there's
guys that like can take the rejection
which is like kind of attractive when
you can
reject the guy first be like oh well i'm
not initially attracted to you but they
handle it really well yeah and then they
kind of like throw it back at you like
you know what i'm saying like that can
kind of build an attraction eventually
over time when they handle the fact that
you're not into them very well you know
you know what i'm saying
it just that shows like the confidence
that they have
they always say like
if a girl makes you wait then she's not
attracted to you do you think that's
true
wait if a girl like makes you wait for
sex then she's not attracted to you
and i feel like a lot of girls do that
because there's so many [ __ ] boys yeah
and they don't want to just be the
like hidden
well that's it because women are more
risk averse typically than men so like
we have to deal with if we get the wrong
std like we can't have kids someday and
that's something men like tip don't have
to deal with as much
no that's what i've heard i've heard
i've heard horror stories oh my gosh i
heard oh my gosh in my first school
someone told me a horror story of um
this girl like it was like the first guy
she slept with and she got an std that
she couldn't have kids
because he was yeah yeah
i don't know
i don't know um
how
okay wait i don't deal with [ __ ] okay
blah blah blah
the it's a lot better now the sound the
sound the feed sound is coming from the
room
noise that pearl's picking up but you
can still hear them
okay well we'll see that's a later
problem
how do you balance being persistent and
not getting like me too like they don't
want to become off as like creepy or
like too much so easy are you kidding me
like really if you're like a logical
person it's not that [ __ ] hard like
there's boundaries there really is and
it's like take your time like okay so
like for example
the guy that i am with like have been
with for the past year mm-hmm
complicated
but
he for a whole year like would just kind
of sometimes i post something on
instagram like oh like
like put me onto some music
initially it was like oh like i really
think you're cute i'm like oh well i'm
not interested but then it was like
little things but eventually a lot of
little things and i was like okay um
but if it's someone who's like so how
would a guy know the difference between
that and you not being interested at all
do you mean because there's some guys
you would
first you okay do you think any guy but
but do you think any guy like because in
my opinion not every guy can escape the
friend zone like there are some guys
that are so hard in the face
oh for sure for sure being creepy
that is a fine line mm-hmm that is a
fine line like i know plenty of guys
that like
they've crossed that oh yeah i will
never speak to you again like it got
creepy
so it's like i feel like if someone's
gonna reject you at a certain point it's
like
no i know i just i think
i think like it's i can understand from
the guy's point of view though like it
could be confusing because i think like
some things like a guy does and if he's
hot like girls will like it and if he's
ugly like girls won't do you agree with
that or disagree like um
oh hold on hold on did thank you for the
super chat very much did i just say the
wrong std yes that is what i said
20
thank you thank you yeah 20 bucks
so
30 so far
30 so far for the stream
because i said i said if you get the
wrong std like like you don't want to
get like even even
okay
i mean there are some that ruin your
life more than others like
no i don't remember what i was saying i
was i was just confused about the wrong
std i'm like there's nobody wrong
let's have a shot to that yeah thank you
ninja washer for life
[Music]
can you already pour it did you take
that one
very dramatically okay the difference is
if he's hot can we get a unique nickname
no um
oh yeah what i was saying holidays first
[Music]
i'm done for the night
[Music]
um
like each person has like a different
level of attractiveness or like
attraction to someone else you know
you can't just say like oh like one
person is hot so like whatever that
person does to everyone else
so i feel like um
yeah
i don't really remember
like there's also like
objective like there's people who are
objectively attractive like i can say
you guys are objectively attractive
right like you know
you know like no like i'm being serious
like
objectively like no like personal thing
like you are all very attractive but
like subjectively like my type might be
different right so it's like
subjectively like i don't think that
well
we can even say this being like tall
women like there are some guys that are
so into tall girls like they're so we
are like
gods to them like they're like you're
six foot like but then there's some but
then there's some guys that are like oh
my god get you started go ahead there's
some guys that the guys are like that
they're like so in a tall woman or also
just like would want a woman to like
be a dominatrix like [ __ ] like
stick on their [ __ ] like face and
whip up oh my god everyone look at it
like dominatrix like
[Music]
at least with the tall woman stereotype
i feel like that's something that i've
kind of
found that's what well i've just found
that like some guys
do not like that you're tall like they i
mean i don't think guys are that picky
in general because like even on dating
apps like women are men swipe on right
on women like 50 of the time where women
only swipe right on men like five to ten
percent of the time so it's very
go ahead women or men that don't like
tall women
tend to have ego issues
[Music]
well i think i think some guys just a
lot of girl they can like pick up and
like it's just
a little bit yes
oh my gosh thank you thank you for the
super chat thank you for the super chat
there's no benefit or reason to be in
the friend zone if she doesn't want you
move on and build up increase your value
and increase your options what do you
guys think of that can you can you say
that
sorry sir sorry sorry
yeah there's no point in being in that
world i feel like it's i feel like a lot
of guys who say they're in the friend
zone say that because they're trying to
get out of the friend zone yeah and like
if you don't see this girl as your
friend why are you still being friends
with her obviously she's not attracted
to like that yeah and i feel like that
just makes like women feel like [ __ ]
sometimes because you like you think
that they're your friend or whatever but
they don't know
they're just waiting for the moment to
[ __ ] you
mm-hmm and that's upsetting yeah it
definitely depends on how they're coming
from that comment because if it's like
there's no benefit of like waiting in
the friend zone until they like are
suddenly attracted she's like yeah
you're right like you know how it should
work anyway yeah between friendzone is
just like oh we're friends and then
maybe one's attracted to the other but
then it's like then it gets tricky if
that's never mm-hmm
so you guys kind of agree with that
advice like you don't think you like you
should wait around in the friend zone if
you want to date her like you should
move on
another five dollars
guys
guys
this is all
all the money is going towards i want to
get eight microphones
drinks here are about
seven dollars a pop there's four of us
which is about 70 pounds sorry
so that's about ten dollars yeah you
would you guys prefer this is a super
chat from cold steel so thank you
um i'm gonna put you on the screen for a
second appreciate you um would you guys
prefer would the ladies prefer a
boyfriend to lead you on a camping trip
in the wilderness or to take you to a
luxury resort
i would love both
no you only get to pick one
like yeah you're talking to a guy and
you're like interested but you're like
kind of
like iffy
i would rather have a luxury resort
because like you can't trip a blank you
might kill me what if you're ted
i'm being serious though because why not
it depends on the situation like for
sure it depends on the situation like
i would okay personally if it was like
someone that i'm super into
and like whatever like i would do a
camping trip because you that's raw like
you can really like get to know somebody
in a raw app yeah yeah
but in general
if it's not like a special connection oh
luxury hotel but also it's like [ __ ]
like why would i not choose a luxury
hotel
i would say like a camping trip in the
wilderness for like you know like a
getaway and then like maybe like a
celebration like a luxury resort you
know okay but you know like yeah
okay we won't deny any we won't
mine is
[Applause]
is
thank you for another 10 super chat
there's no no question but if you had
one
um okay
okay what if a guy doesn't want a tall
girl it's insecure ego why can't men
just have preferences that's fine
there's nothing wrong with that oh but
earlier you've just said yeah because
earlier you said if he doesn't like tall
girls like a lot of times it's their ego
yeah but it does
no like that's fine but a lot of the
times when men are not attracted to
taller women it has to do with their ego
oh because of the yeah like for me when
i don't want to be with shorter guys
it's because my ego okay that's 100
really yeah for me i'm just like not as
attracted to them like i'm not as
attracted to it either
but i'm not but here's the thing like
okay we're talking about this like i'm
not attracted to as attracted to a
shorter man either because of my ego
like if we're really looking at it at
that standpoint because my ego was like
well i'm bigger than him in this way
no i'm not going to be as attracted to
that as a man is not going to be as
mostly like
a man is not going to be as attractive
to a woman that is bigger than him like
yeah most of the time like physically
like taller
there's nothing wrong with that but it
is all ego it's all ego is it okay could
it be ego or is it more of like your own
insecurities right but then it's like
are you going to be with someone that
makes you feel comfortable
insecure it's not necessarily anyone's
fault
but i have to say with men like sorry
but men are a lot more egotistical
egotistical than women
that's just like oh my god i disagree
oh my god i don't think we are
[Music]
but it's not 80 of women make consumer
purchasing decisions so that's like
everything is marketed and geared
towards women
like we hear like like fat is beautiful
like that's all over nowadays yes yes it
is
yes it is people are finally realizing
that okay okay okay
okay hold on hold on hold on
sorry what what's your youtube channel
oh it's just pearly things just pearly
things just pearly things
[Music]
okay all i have to say is that
mainstream media does not say fat is
beautiful at all mainstream media has no
say okay what's mainstream what's
mainstream media media is kim kardashian
is flat stomach okay big boobs big bucks
you really think kim kardashian's main
street
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go off of that
and it's not necessarily saying
it's saying like your natural body and
your natural state is beautiful because
kim is praised
i don't even believe that like honestly
like i feel like main street like okay
the male's like general idea of what
beautiful is
like
boobs
no stomach fat
oh for sure yeah their mind like what
that means because for me what ass might
mean to me is like not what ass means to
you you know what i'm saying like but
that's like what a man's like idea of
i i don't think many men believe
wait wait i think the door is open hi
[Applause]
i feel like men's preferences have also
changed no for sure and like as like for
women like we prefer like everyone has
like a different preference men also do
that too you know like yeah all the like
skinny body big boots like you know some
like like snow boots no but whatever
just
oh my god thank you for the donation
gabby okay this is for okay
you've got
i'm 6'3 i had a tall girl but for four
shorter women i've never had an ego in
security but watching a talk
like insecurity watching the tall girl
in the ides
and fat is not hot what do you think
about that
because you said men's preferences have
changed okay wait repeat it here do you
want to read it yeah
yeah
you spelled my name wrong
let's get it right
baby baby
you're not a [ __ ]
[Music]
but she just said it's it's about like
ego both ways
prefer shorter women okay but never had
ego insecurity watching this whole girl
in the eyes and fat is not hot
watching this i don't like that
[Music]
okay
that's your preference that's fine
but like
personally
that i feel like that is your preference
is because
your ego is telling you you cannot be
with a woman
like to be with a woman that's taller
than you is like
no i don't know
i think men i think men are just like
attracted to women smaller than them
because that's rooted in pedophilia we
can really get into that
and like women that are shorter than
them specifically pedophilia
i don't know
well based on what
but you could just like with like like i
like guys that are thinner too is that
rooted in pedophilia i like skinny like
basketball player bodies
yeah
yeah but what if i like shorter guys
would that be rooted in pedophilia what
if i do
really
if you were to tell me if you were to
tell me that you liked men that were
like 5'3 and that were
like built like children because women
were short
i would say
you think
you think what you think canico's built
like a child she's short no no i'm
saying like
yeah saying that like men that are
specific that are usually specifically
attracted to women that are supers
and are built like children
it's rooted in pedophilia and that's why
okay that's my personal opinion
don't care how tall you are to take a
ride
that's my personal opinion you don't
have to agree with me it's okay
[Applause]
um height is a requirement that women
have men don't care how tall you are to
take a ride is that what you just read
no that's what i'm saying like as a
woman not reporting that
everything's live this is live it's a
live stream recording
recording
oh reporting no no no no like people are
watching
thirty-three
can i have some apple juice oh yeah
[Music]
my parents are on youtube all the time
so my parents follow her
oh
this is kind of fun right
um
i know my friends might find this and be
like eileen what the [ __ ]
love my short kings
oh my god don't even get me started on
the shortcast
actually this is going to be my next
question how tall are you and how tall
do you prefer a guy i'm saying i'd love
it i am 510 i would say
if they're just like my height or a
little taller then what's your like
perfect height do you have one not
really oh you don't really care i feel
like i'm so tall i can't really have
like a perfect higher so there's so many
i'm limited you know also all the shark
[ __ ] take the tall boys they always
do
okay
if you wanna sit here you can grab a
chair oh my god i have a like a vision a
piano
in my bedroom just go grab it i'll put
you right here
wait to that
wait
oh no no no you guys really like
no what
[Music]
okay first of all short people don't
call them midgets they're
is
okay
if i didn't if i like small people is
that
yes okay personally in my opinion like
under eyes
okay what i dated a man
[Applause]
[Music]
yes i was 15 he was 24 and he told me
that he had a thing for midgets
[Music]
so my personal personal experience would
say otherwise like you know what i'm
saying i feel like there's one thing if
you're like
oh
i love this person they happen to be
they're small yes versus
yes
or whatever but like i feel like there
is a big problem
like
that's not to say that there's not a lot
of men that wouldn't be attracted to ah
i'm sure i can move the table
[Music]
and you're like well i'm attracted to
small people yes i would say that is
creepy can i take an ice cube what yeah
that's on my channel but okay
what were we talking about before that
question that was raised
um i asked how tall you are and what
your ideal height is
shorter than me and i didn't even notice
i was like oh my god austin is so hot
and everyone's like he's shorter than
you i was like i didn't even notice
do you have like a perfect height like
so your 5 9 roster height what's like
ideal like build a man right
okay like it's not it's not a bad thing
we just so you know we all acknowledge
we all acknowledge none of us are
perfect we don't expect a guy to be
perfect
okay well i don't and i'm sure you don't
either but like just like build a guide
also if if you guys want to say anything
on the mic just make sure you like yeah
because they're they're not
yeah they're they're not gonna hear you
otherwise
are you coming in yeah
yeah well you you have this the school
yeah in the back yeah yeah yeah
why don't i think next to g is going to
be the best so if g scoots a little
bit
also guys feel free to send a donation
all donations are going to be
for um
so we have enough mics over here because
right now we have to share mics
questions yeah cause look at how many of
us there are
look at it and the more the more money
we raise for this podcast the more mics
i can do and i need to raise about a
thousand more dollars to get another set
of mics and another soundboard
this is this is cute
all right okay okay okay um i'm gonna
start with my height and my height
requirement so my height is six foot the
lowest i would really go is like five
ten like an inch or two shorter
and but ideally like honestly six seven
that's my like perfect height oh if a
guy sticks i know that's rare though so
i don't like expect that
[Music]
i wonder how the will how this will go
with
cash app is just pearly things just i'll
put this
i wonder how this will go with andrew
taylor it's
andrew tate
it's a whole different sector it's a
weird sector of youtube
um but sorry go ahead so you're six
three how tall do you want a guy to be
personally like if i could pick yeah
whatever the [ __ ] i wanted like six
seven six eight okay yeah me too yeah my
man is six two
but he's perfect
so
you gotta eat it give some take some
like well yeah that's the thing like we
don't expect a guy to be perfect this is
just like a guy can say oh i want a girl
with ass and tits but he'd be fine with
just after just hits half the time now
like he's only six two but like he
checks off every other box like
yeah he's
smart like
he's
[Music]
you sure about the last one
i gotta compete
he he has done it for me at least for
the last year
[Music]
okay
[Laughter]
um
how much was that bottle of coconut
fun fact this is probably like two
thousand dollars worth of equipment
like between the camera
it's probably more actually
um
any questions
okay what
you're getting mad
okay
okay g what about your height yeah your
height how tall
your height ideal height
i'm speaking a bit mike so you have to
put it like here yeah
and choose yourself
oh yeah
tell them your name tell them if you're
single or taken
and tell them your height and your ideal
height um g money
yes sir yes sir
[Music]
what was it your height
and ideal height like
preference
[Music]
what do you guys think the average
height is for men
i've been told it's five nine i think
it's like i mean
your turn to intro five time
you are you are someone's fiance
oh your ring looks so pretty i've been
singing
wow that's so pretty
um
i also am the same as asheville like i
don't think i noticed height because
i was in two for a while i'm not a short
king but like
my height but like looked a lot shorter
because it's longer torso than i did
but
that was like as short as i'll go like
you have to be mine
sorry you have to be my at least and
then but michael only has 86 foot so
that's not enough for me that's that's
what i always say is girls don't need
like like crazy height we just want a
guy that's taller than us like that's
been the most like
or the same height yeah because i don't
even mind like i feel like some girls
are like like
i want to be able to wear heels too
okay okay hold on hold on one thing okay
guys guys anyone that puts anything rude
about people in the chat i will block
you i'm just going to put that i'm going
to know i'm going to put this right here
what did they say
or is this just a warning
this is just a warning so if you put
anything rude anything no it wasn't
about you
know it's about no one saying no
no no i'm just putting i'm just warning
them now because people get wild in the
comments they say wild stuffed all the
time
do they have um what's it called people
moderators at youtube or if you see the
tick tock do you know what i'm talking
about yeah i have moderators but like
you don't know when they're honored i
don't have a lot so i'm usually like i
don't again i don't get like crazy
numbers so it's like
i can usually just block people but i'm
not paying attention
i split maniac you're going off in the
comments
[Music]
yeah we're lying to you um this is mild
compared to fresh and i'm telling you
you saw austin you wouldn't notice
height either
say this
[Music]
put on a good show
lemonade bay is my moderator actually
okay i feel like this is like a little
bit
do you want apple juice
what are you kind of mixing up
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
oh yeah i've heard of them okay old
school yeah are you watching them on
they are coming june 25th and there it's
40 pounds of ticket but i would love to
go
like they're like alive it's like insane
i would any concert is a good monster
okay
any concert is
[Music]
oh no they want to know if they can
roast people no no no no this is uh
no i know that's like what i was
thinking too oh there it goes there's
the lighting it's getting better i'm
trying to show that music playing
[Music]
okay actually i have a question i have a
question
is this the music yeah
[Music]
okay
are you would you guys be okay with
coffee as a first date go around gabby
first
if someone asked me for coffee the first
time i would be like yes
starbucks
is that different
[Applause]
i also like the idea of a date a daytime
date i think it's really nice i like the
first day with michael coffee it was
lunch
[Music]
see i prefer duncan though over star
wars
do they have duncan here
i think they do but it's just not the
same anywhere else
yeah
i don't think you play music
why are people upset about
it's okay
ladies are you what do you guys think of
zodie who believes in zodiac signs here
raise your hand if you believe in zodiac
signs
okay so yes yes not really yes all i
know is everything
no
okay
what about what about you g yes or no
yes
yes okay so it's like half and
half everything
that's how i feel too that's what i
think
[Music]
why is spotify though um because it's
better
you think you have more than one song
easier to use okay
do you guys have income requirements for
a guy like he has to make a certain
amount of money
so if a guy was making 30 000 a year
okay wait wait what what up
okay
would
did anyone say they cared about salary
anyone
okay would you date a guy that's working
at a gas station
okay okay everyone okay okay okay
everyone everyone i'm trying to go one
at a time otherwise it picks everyone
else up okay so okay so you go ahead
guys there's a difference because here's
the thing it's about motivation if
you're working at a gas station and you
have you're working towards a degree for
like a higher
something then that's different but if
you're just working at a gas station
because you're like oh [ __ ]
we're just going to work at a guest
and that's different there's a
difference there genuinely is like like
there's something that's very attractive
about a man that like is striving for
something greater yeah and i understand
a lot of things that are greater take
time and energy and a lot of getting
[ __ ]
[Music]
so you would you guys be cool with a guy
working at a gas station because he's
saving money to build a business or
something yes
this is already built
okay does your significant other have to
have the same hobbies as you no no no
absolutely not
look like some space
i think it's fun to have different
things because then you get to do like
you take turns doing what the other one
was oh my god i was just going to say
that right
are you actually getting your baby
no i was being serious
because it's more fun that way what
you're saying new things
also and you get stuck
ain't no woman here dating
why don't
okay how about income and job without
any considering any future expectations
of salary or status here's the thing
wait we are younger than i think you
guys are talking about like we are all
still in school like no one in our
what's the youngest person 23 you 22.
yeah you're 22.
whoa
yeah
my birthday's in august we are the same
age
love
what
okay but we should we should go it's 11
30.
i do love those
um oh my gosh i don't know what to let's
go
okay wait okay
i'm not ready this is how we meet random
people
all right let's go okay guys okay guys
thanks for watching this test i
appreciate all of you um thank you so
much for the donations i think we got
like
sorry is there another donation or
something no i was just gonna say fall
what
go ahead go ahead go ahead you can
promote it go ahead that's fine anyone
that comes up anyone that comes on like
you can promote whatever yeah you got
instagram oh yeah instagram oh yeah
[Music]
oh that's my instagram is bts you're
getting them done my instagram is yeah
i'm 14.
um
[Music]
[Applause]
wait
top yeah my oyster card
so i can travel
help me out in london
oh we need it i'm trying to get to
practice every friday night
girl girl bring it home okay thank you
guys so much for the donations today as
you guys know we are saving for the next
sound board so we can get eight mics so
we can have eight people on here isn't
it annoying everyone having to like go
back and forth between mike's you can
barely hear us
you can barely hear us shoot put put
some money in the chat please anyways um
thank you for watching
and do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification bell
i will talk to you guys next time